hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to another three scary
games
what
you expecting something
[Music]
anyway this is leftovers um
there's something about how you don't
need to do uh something and then in
hi
boy i need your help please okay why is
the picture of dad all obscured why is
our tv just a white box
okay what do you need mom
talk mom
sorry mom i cooked too much today can
you be a dear please and give the
leftovers away to our neighbors
oh
mark respond by nodding or shaking your
head with the mouse
no
it's okay dear they're not gonna bite
you'll have to be a big boy one day and
learn to take care of your mom all right
don't be like your dad
all right i put 10 boxes of leftovers in
the bag beside you pick it up for me
no
ten boxes that's you didn't just cook a
little bit more you cooked a whole lot
more
i i'm sorry for troubling you dear but
mommy's busy with dinner i know i've
taught you to never talk to strangers
but you're not gonna let me down right
okay ma
good luck dear
why do i need luck ma
ma
mom
mommy what's gonna happen to me if i
need luck by the way don't come back
until you're done okay
okay ma
this is a drug drop isn't it my mom
is a drug dealer not my real mom
maybe
my mama's not a drug dealer hey neighbor
god i remember doing this
when i was uh
[Music]
hello you must be the little boy from
next door what brings you here
i don't know if that's your nose or if
that's your mouth
or if that's your mouth here you go
what's this oh it's your mouth okay
my favorite please give my thanks to
your parents for me by the way have you
been a good boy
no
ah you silly boy sometimes being honest
is not always a good thing well
goodnight now
okay
thanks
all right
okay
nine left
knock knock knock
what do you want what's wrong with your
face
the food
this smells delicious
do i need to pay
no
what an idi okay
what
what am i the idiot for not tricking you
into paying for something that i okay
that makes sense that's fine i feel good
about myself
i have not been a good boy have i
hi
hello
okay you're a little close
food
your mom's leftovers nobody wants that
you ever gonna breathe out
wait are you the son of that beautiful
chick from level nine
yes
um i'll say i'll be sure to savor this
wall it's still warm then
okay
man
what lovely neighbors
i just realized sounds like someone's
taking a shower i should come back later
i realized like there's nine floors
which probably means that there's more
than 10 people that could accept so
maybe i shouldn't give to certain people
the food
but alas here i am
[Music]
hi
what do you want kid i'm busy
food
seriously
i guess it's somewhat tiring work you
know what just leave it outside the door
thanks
okay you could just take it
how do i oh
there you go pal why'd you leave your
door open
i want a little peek
okay
i can't go on anymore mommy
mommy
dear why are you home so early didn't i
tell you not to come back until you're
done but sorry dear mommy's really busy
right now i'm sure the neighbors aren't
that much of a trouble right you can do
it please go back out there and make
mommy proud okay mommy you got it mommy
i could just give
all of them to the old lady i suppose
no i can't
i gotta keep going i'm not hearing the
slurping sounds of people enjoying my
mom's cooking
you'd think that it would be echoing
down the hallways of pure bliss and
enjoyment
hello
yeah one time i had to do a fundraiser
for school and i went door-to-door in an
apartment complex and it was just the
worst i sold one thing
hi
oh
well aren't you an adorable one what
brings you here
food
my my how thoughtful of you you must be
tired from walking up and down the
stairs how about you come in and rest
for a while
no
i'm not gonna do that
oh maybe next time yeah maybe never
okay bye forever
looks like no one is home are you sure
about that
oh yeah there was a person showering
upstairs
all right no one's home
i'll check back
later
i remember specifically one person was
in the shower and was so pissed off that
they had to come to the door
i don't want to talk to her she's just
gonna bully me like in school
okay
[Music]
looks like no one is home
i guess no one is home
oh why is that open
hello
[Music]
oh oh oh oh oh
what
boy are you seriously back again are you
trying to make mommy upset but mummy
enough boy you probably did something
you're not supposed to right don't poke
your nose into something that could get
you in trouble don't be like your dad
[Music]
okay
okay ma
you got him uh all right so lesson
learned i probably only have one more
shot to deliver all the food and i gotta
be a good boy i probably should have
placed it before uh
before they
got to the door okay it was this floor
and it was that door
no one's home
well i definitely don't want to go to
that one again
i've got four boxes of food and three
flights of stairs left
surely someone will want this food
nope
alrighty then
poppy
puppy
hello
[Music]
hi
yeah what do you want
i got food
oh man you caught me in the best timing
possible i almost decided to just eat
this little
never mind thank you
we used to have a bag of food down there
but some school girl kept trying to
steal it i guess she succeeded ah
goodbye
could that school girl be
my arch nemesis from school i think that
was all the way up in floor five i don't
think it was this one i think this one's
no one's home
yeah no
yeah it was floor five definitely hi
as much as i love hearing you bully me
you gotta give back the dog food or else
this person's gonna eat their dog
and that's no good
hi
oh
wow you're
a little crab
[Music]
because i see your ugly face that's what
makes me cry anyway what are you doing
here without your mummy and daddy is
that food i smell give it to me
no
you had some nerves hand it over why do
you always have to make things difficult
for me you think i'm the one stealing
their food damn right i am i've hidden
it away i got to teach that man a lesson
his dog licked me the other day how
disgusting dog germs someone call an
ambulance call the fire department his
dog will probably starve to death any
time now
don't think about ruining my plan
all right
great maybe i should just give that guy
another plate of food so his dog doesn't
starve also he could go buy more food no
whatever it's all fine
i got two plates left
and that's it
and somewhere there's some dog food i
don't know where though
hello
hi
oh you have a knife
what are you doing here boy
food
oh it's fine little one i'm not hungry
at all how about a chat instead
no thank you
hopefully
thank you it's been a long time since i
had a chat you see
my wife just passed recently
so it gets
pretty lonely after a while
especially this place
gets to you eventually
for example
it felt like it was only yesterday that
i met my wife
at the same time
it felt like it was only yesterday that
i found her lifeless body with a knife
stuck in her throat
i'm gonna cut to the chase boy
tell me do you think that it's wrong for
an innocent person to get murdered
yes
do you think anger is normal when
someone hurts our loved ones
[Music]
yes
do you think murderers should be
punished
do you think i'm the murderer food
food food you want food
okay yes then if you found out your
loved ones for example your mom is a
murderer do you think she should be
punished i mean yeah
technically so honest so innocent it
seems that all is not lost
come in and rest for a bit i insist
okay
don't worry about your mum
i'll get it
oh
i guess i didn't do it right i should
have been more cheerful and chipper in
this i went as like a little baby
approach i should have just been like
thumbs up man
what are you doing here boy food hey
food
i'm not hungry how about we chat instead
no okay
thank you it's been a long time my wife
just passed pretty lonely after a while
especially this place it could see
eventually it feels like yesterday only
but at the same time it was like it was
only yesterday that i found her lifeless
body with a knife suck in her throat i'm
gonna cut to the chase boy do you think
it's wrong for an innocent person to get
murdered
no
i see the son of the devil is finally
upon me
out maybe i'll just not go to that door
maybe i'll just not you know
hey is that dog food
wow
i found the stolen dog food
no one is home
hello there's a kind of a stabby man
upstairs
hi how you doing
oh hey
is this the rumored tradition whenever a
new neighbor moves in yes
sure
yes oh food wow yes
sorry i've never experienced it before
ha
what's this dish called
i don't know
i remember dad's friend lives on level
seven
uh sorry i don't to sound ungrateful but
it looks so slimy
thanks i guess
wait is that an eyeball
oh
so me mom is indeed a murderer i don't
know what to do about that was it this
floor that had the dog no it was down
one more i think it was down one
actually i think it was down even one
more i found your dog food please donate
your paparino
duh i'm always done one more
you got back our food thank god just put
the bag back
crap gotta go kids thanks again what
happened
what what
all right whatever
there you go
well
what are you gonna do about nerd
all right
you'll regret this
will i
did i you mad that someone's not gonna
have to eat their own dog
well something to be mad about
all right
[Music]
hi
are you my dad's friend i can see why
you're such good friends with my dad hi
hey you're the cute kid from level nine
what are you doing all alone at night
food you want food oh you cutie you must
be so tired oh wow
your mom really made this i just have to
know her recipe
hi hilary it's me laura
yeah your sweet little kid just handed
it to me
kenneth is a very lucky man to have you
cook for him every day huh
what do you mean was
ah let me guess he finally told you
about us
huh what do you mean that's not what you
meant
you psycho you better not move kid
i need to go home to mummy
uh
oh wow my god hi
this is for tricking me to eat that
so-called oh
ow
ouch ouch how i didn't know it was a
chase
well
all right
peek-a-boo oh
uh
hi
hello
oh god you're quick hi no
oh oh oh oh hi hello hi
uh okay again with this this
now all right so then this uh this girl
is
being an
hi what's up can i get by oopsies hi
what are you gonna do uh wait why do you
i just notice your eyeballs are in your
mouth why
okay you can go i'm going home
mom mommy
good job dear
i'm very proud of you
now go to your room and go to bed mommy
got some leftover business to take care
of
i liked i feel like the audio design
could have used some extra love but
i liked it very creepy and off put it
i'm not saying it was bad i'm just
saying it probably needed just a little
more richness to it but the simplicity
did work if that was a style choice i'd
take it back it was totally fine but i
feel like it could have used a little
more but i like that very fun
okay moving on
this is
scp-847 which is actually an sap i'm not
familiar with i can go look that up
scp-847 is to be kept in a reinforced
humanoid containment chamber for the
purpose of ongoing behavioral studies
the room is to be fully furnished with a
bed dresser couch table chair
full-length mirror sink shower and
toilet the floor of the chambers to be
constructed of one centimeter exposed
beams of copper which can be electrified
remotely with to a minimum 50 kilovolts
potential a 50 centimeter squared safe
zone at the rear right corner of the
containment chambers to remain free of
the copper beams in the case of
personnel inside containment chamber
during disabling of ascp-847 no meals
are to be provided all personnel posted
to scp-847 must be armed with a shock
baton rated to 30 kilovolts or greater
only
xy males identifying as such are to be
assigned are permitted within a 50 meter
radius of scp-847 it's a human female
mannequin that's all i need to know
about it that's why there were all these
mannequins in the main menu now it all
makes sense
it's all coming together
oh hi
how are you
are you scp847
i am what you would call an xy male
hi
i missed those other instructions that
were hidden behind my face
okay
well this is definitely gonna go good
for me
sure
oh
it's my favorite descending down into a
basement
always a good time
why am i here
am i one of the personnel i don't think
i remember having a shock baton
okay
i don't see any
exposed copper wiring around here
well that's flooded
awfully quiet
well
as much as i love walking down empty
dark hallways
[Music]
i would often like to know why
hi do i need a generator
am i crazy or am i hearing things
just little things
off to the sides by the way though
youtube those are mannequins don't
demonetize me please well this is
always comforting
knowing that i have no idea why i'm here
or what i'm doing
was i supposed to do something with that
generator probably
oh
all right
again
what is that am i inside a store i'm
inside some kind of a store so there
probably was something oh hang on
no
[Music]
i'm clicking as hard as i can clip
again
why
someone's throwing a tantrum over there
what's the deal what did i get i missed
it because i
i uh was distracted but i got something
it was either a key to a door somewhere
else or
some useful item that's gonna help me in
some other department
but that was easy to miss
so great good
again
i heard the thing
what is that
i don't like not knowing what's going on
ah it was a key
okay good
who's telling a funny joke over there
hey hold it for me hey save some
laughter for me
i like a good joke
yeah thanks
oh
are you starting to cry because i'm
approaching and you don't want to tell
the joke anymore and you're sad that i
won't get it
why are you insulting my intelligence
and my ability to get the jokes
look
well
oh
grid
good i bet that probably activated some
kind of a pump
or i need to put a pull press turn
the big red wheel that i saw in the
other room
ah that's
that's lovely
that's good stuff
you'd think that uh
you'd think that a building like this
might actually have good electricity and
wouldn't need to rely on a generator
i did it
okay
thanks for closing the door for me how
you doing
i am what you call an xy male
oh
i'm sorry did that offend you
oh i can't get out
i didn't want to anyway i wanted to go
down here oh no never mind i can't
why can't i oh now i can
that's i am not an xy male
i am not an xy male
someone having a good time over here is
that someone hey
okay
that's fine what do i see here
[Music]
sucks
i don't know this is probably some kind
of a puzzle
there's definitely ah i see
okay
well this is going to take some doing
all right
oh thankfully i think it's in the same
order as that one i see there must be
some kind of
symbols that's a symbol that i think was
on the list uh
[Music]
hey
howdy neighbor how you doing hey good to
see you you having a good time over
there good
okay so we do have cymbals we got like
that cog wheel and
a cog and like a ribbon i'm not seeing
that on here i see the cog but oh it's
top zx okay so 17
and that's a swirly whirlpool
which is
a a 11 so it's either 11 17 or 17 11.
yeah oh it's six numbers okay so there's
one more here
oh there it is
eyeball cog
cog ball n f oh there's one there too
but i oh yeah that's there too that
means there are four okay so we had k
which is eight
and f
ninety two eight well that's too many
numbers 92 8 11 17. that's
one too many numbers oh no wait one two
it's okay
right so there are enough numbers okay
let's just do a 19 92 17 8 and 11 9 2 17
8 11.
nope okay there must be something that
tells me the order ah here we go
one two three
three
one two
i guess we could just try all the
different combinations let's try
eleven seventeen eleven seventeen nine
two eight seventeen eleven
eight
oh oh
i did it
i i did it i thought i would have got
that by now but
turns out it was the very last one that
i could
brute force hey what's going on pal
hey what's going on buddy
okay uh
okay
oh who wants to play peek-a-boo
come on who wants to play
i know i do
i don't
who is that
someone wants some peekaboo
i see you i don't see anything please i
don't want to see anything i'd rather
see nothing actually i don't want to be
blind
don't blind me don't do it oh okay those
are my eyes oh ow
oh ow
ouch
oh beautiful
oh oh oh
oh oh i'm dead
i'm going towards the light
this is lovely
really lovely
i like it a lot
hey this ain't so bad
you eater can you tell me what you are
can you understand me
oh cool good
great how did you learn to do this do
what
how old are you
that doesn't make any sense do you know
who i am
[Applause]
thanks do you know what a doctor is
in your own fashion at least
oh so i'm not a medical doctor i have a
doctorate could you tell me what you are
[Applause]
a doctor
could you be more specific
i shall enlighten you okay cool thank
you
how do you enlighten people
okay all right we're gonna be a little
pedantic are we what do you think
so it could just be two plus two could
you explain what you mean
[Applause]
okay
i do not wish to do that at the moment
may i ask you some more questions
[Applause]
can you teach me through talking to me
okay
hey wait i didn't say i didn't want to
be enlightened
[Music]
you know that was a little bit of a
strange endeavor i don't know why
that happened but apparently i have not
been enlightened so i'm just as stupid
as i was when i entered this shop
looking for a
sale of some kind i'm assuming or to
steal something i'm back now
i'm bleeding now i'm a mannequin now
[Music]
oh
i guess i am a mannequin
did that cause my enlightenment you know
if i was gonna die either way i think i
would have taken the enlightenment
pretty cool i hadn't even heard of that
scp it was in the top thousand and i
never even looked at it
pretty cool i like it
moving on this well hey how you doing
over there this is the apartment it's
apparently an unfinished game with a
quickly done ending oh
okay
oh hi
i've not heard from my brother for a few
weeks now and i start to worry a bit i
have decided to go visit him in his
apartment to see if there's anything
wrong
all right
oh
okay let's see my brother lives in
apartment 24. if only i brought my
glasses i can't really read those
numbers from here
uh 24 i hope it's not the flickering one
here's 20.
knock knock anybody seen my brother this
is dark
well it just ends there so that's fine
hello
knock knock
anybody home
all right
either these doorways are small or i'm
rather tall hello
all right i swear i know my numbers i'm
just checking if there's anything else
bottle recycling right this is a
department 24.
oh my camera's gone
well that's inconvenient lexian put up a
uh artist's rendition of my face no need
to animate the mouth or anything like
that unless you could do just a quick
automated to my voice signal thing
waveform whatnot whatever if that's too
much work abandon the process
and
never even remember that i asked to do
it in the first place and berate me
heavily insult me hello
at some point my camera will come back
but for now this is the way that we live
this is what we have hello
it's in the basement
great coming from the trees well which
is it these are two different things
hello
not my brother speaking
i said hello
you laughing or crying
i'm gonna go with laughing i'm an
optimist
hello
all right
well brother what lovely art you've
chosen to decorate your house with
i think that's a light switch over here
the roots roots everywhere
okay
good why
hold on
hold on hold
hold my now my camera is charging for
some reason it it was plugged in but the
bat whatever you don't care
oh
i'm sorry someone in the bathroom
i'm coming in
i'm coming in all right fine
be that way
i'm not coming in there
hello
all right
something about roots something about
coming from
all right
yeah i don't need to watch that that'll
rot my brain
roots all right you telling me to
remember my roots
remember my brother is there something
behind here oh this must be the keys for
the kitchen door i didn't know the
kitchen door could have its own key
there's something behind there all right
let's see if my camera's back hello
all right i'm back let's see how long it
lasts
probably not long hello
right
well
oh you know i don't need to go in there
i'm just gonna say i don't need to go in
there
i don't need to and i won't and i shan't
and i shouldn't
let me guess that was the kitchen door
there i just couldn't see anything
inside of it
i don't have an inventory do i
you know this didn't seem like it had a
lock
oh what am i what am i hearing
light switch
i can't see anything i
i don't know what that's about
don't go down there down where was this
the kitchen
oh
i think there's a light switch i'm going
for it
[Music]
okay is that a bone
whoa is my brother cooking up
smells delicious
nice pizza
his door is locked but why
feel like there's something important
here but i'm not seeing it
okay
what is that
the penis
oh ah
he's the bedroom door
great what a secure house we have here
my brother was one for safety
didn't seem to save him though brother
are you there
okay
there are no bedrooms here
oh it must have like i said i don't know
why i keep going back when there's a
door in there that i did not try of
course
of course
that's what i get for showing my face
around here
there is no need
shhh
looking at this weird
baby
trophy stop
yes this makes sense
are those roots i see
oh
hmm good
great
well any other keys
root killer
ah oh
wow
nice book
um can i burn you
no
maybe i could uh get a
get a like a can of hairspray and make a
flamethrower
uh light this heat up some food what do
i need the lighter for
it's light
that's what
take this and this
take this all right fine you're not
doing anything
which is okay i get it i understand
it's fine
power went out i think there's a utility
room in the hallway outside uh so this
oh my god
[Music]
good thing i went in the closet
[Applause]
i'm gonna just go now what was in here
you were in the bathroom
oh god
who's behind the curtain
who
was behind the curtain i'll burn it down
hi hello
[Music]
ah that's what i thought a hallucination
caused by my brother's rampant growing
of this new strain of weed very powerful
all right anyway go turn the power on
and not run away screaming at the top of
my lungs
hi
well can't open that so i guess i'm just
screwed
was it out here i should get the utility
room key hanging from the lamp in the
closet before i leave of course
that is a very specific hint good thing
i knew that and notice that good thing
good thing oh
oh
that is hard to see
he's for the utility room out in the
hallway why did my brother have this i
don't know
a little bit of mosey on my way
well see you around bro
i am out of here and never coming back
hello
utility
utilita
yeah oh
hey
uh
what the hell is this yeah what the hell
is this not what the hell was everything
that was happening in my brother's
apartment
that specifically
all right
hello any root problems kind of reminds
me of um
dark wood which i freaking loved
i wasn't too happy about how it ended
but whatever
the exit is blocked by these strange
roots how it ended for me specifically
not necessarily how it ended in general
ah there was a door here
in the darkness
that which controls power has no light
how ironic is that pizza
no is that a tampon
maybe
uh 24
power on need to get back to the
apartment but why
you want some of this you want a piece
of me
huh
[Music]
well i won pretty sure that was obvious
okay so apparently don't go charging at
the giant root monster that's
about to
blow your brains out i guess i won't do
a final confrontation of epic
proportions
it's me against the villain my last
stand
the only one left yeah
no
i need to switch the breaker
you're probably right
i'm trying to
aha i had to click it sometimes you have
to click sometimes you don't
so what do i do about you
pal
oh you know what i'm gonna go back here
nah
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh
[Music]
okay well that was apparently not the
answer or maybe it was that i wasn't
supposed to stand directly in front of
the doorway where it could have come
charged at me maybe that was the thing
that got me good i thought i had it
i thought i had it apparently i did not
have it
hours back on all right let me try
dodging it
all right buddy come at me come at me
you can't you can't oh twinkle pose over
there you think you can watch this
he still gets you
turns out he's go get you maybe i do got
to do the matador style kind of just
like get to the room and then don't
stand directly in front of the door
where he could get me because his
twinkle toes be twonkling come at me
okay i'm gonna stand right here
he can never get me whoa what am i
seeing
what i can't see
i'm going
i'm just gonna run for it
i made it i survived
i'm fine
get back to this apartment definitely
this is where i need to go
i would be tearing those roots down with
my bare hands
okay
i'm back home now
this is pretty well made i'm really
happy with this i don't know why it
didn't get finished
oh
seems to be a few more roots than there
once were
ah
fun
oh
ah
ah tv you're gonna turn on you're gonna
turn on you're gonna turn on you're
gonna turn on
didn't think so
all right
love going in a basement
what did i just hear
what was that what is this
where's my lighter i'm going for it
hi
are you the great spirit of the tree
that lurks behind below my brother's
apartment
oh
oh my god what is this this is where it
all comes from
hey bro is that you trapped in there
i should really get out of here and get
some help oh yeah now
now i would agree with you i
i do agree uh all right oh oh
oh oh
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god not now
oh you come right at me
[Music]
i probably have to ring around the rosie
oh no i just had to die
all right
i like that i like the style really did
a lot with the sound and also just like
the whole tree and root thing i think is
an often overlooked horror element it's
very nice i love it like dark wood
really embraced that with like the
natural horror of the trees it's really
fun stuff but i like that a lot very
good for an unfinished thing felt pretty
finished to me
that'll do it for this episode of three
scary games thank you everybody so much
for watching hope you enjoyed it check
out more scary games that i played
linked in the description many more
spooks waiting for you and as always i
will see you
in the next video
what are you expecting a jump scare
[Music]
what's wrong with you
bye-bye
[Music]